taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic I'm talking taste hey folks
welcome to t-a-s-e-e buds
how's it going
it's gone you know great it's good
how's it going with you terrible yeah
terrible terrible week but uh you know
we're here to talk about food not not uh
problems this isn't the uh
Mark Baron
podcast
[Music]
the uh he gets heavy do you ever do that
show no I did it once it was really fun
it's weird to say it was fun because it
was it was enjoyable but it really has a
real conversation with it's nice is he
that's still going strong right oh yeah
it's like it used to be so huge you just
interviewed Ice Cube
Cube yeah
for some reason Q Ice Cube was like a
like a crazy cat in your opinion
yeah because because like Marin
um
you know he was always like a
socio-political type comic and he you
know he was on air America
so he did like political radio and stuff
like that so like him interviewing a
president is is a huge deal but but it
made more sense and he's also a big
music fan too but like the juxtaposition
of Ice Cube and Marc Maron is yeah was a
little more like whoa that's crazy hey
remember like it used to be like Rogan
and Maron one of the two biggest
podcasts and now like you still hear
about Rogan but I don't hear in general
conversation about the WTF anymore
that could just be me though I was
wondering myself if he um
if he was if he still did it or not
um because he also like he does so much
acting does he yeah I know yeah that his
own show but like he's in so much stuff
man all the time uh and then he tours
still doing stand-ups so I was like I
wonder if he still does the podcast but
then I was like yeah I guess he still
does it like he had to make some Bank
off this thing no
I think it was I mean isn't this isn't
WTF the podcast like isn't like isn't
that the one that kind of started it all
as far as like money and podcasting goes
like real money I mean well
I'm exactly sure but it was one of the
bigger ones besides Rogan definitely
Mount Rushmore he's got 10 best gets in
there for nine best guests well did he
scroll he did WTF break before Rogan did
because Rogan would did it for a while
man doing it like forever yeah
yeah I was doing it like at a desk
um wow they Jenny sleep makes the top
nine huh
Judy
no no I'm just because I'm it's the
president it's you know like I'm just
saying you know Robin Williams you know
so I was doing a slight of Jenny slate
but look at the bar
[Music]
Judy Greer that's so weird I mean I
respect the Judy Greer that's just a
weird
you're not expecting to see that on the
you know like like you said it's the
president
who is she she's an actress uh she was
in a
she's in the new Halloween movie she
plays the daughter in the new Halloween
movies she's in a lot of stuff oh I know
who she is oh I didn't know that was her
name
um that's just an interesting you know
oh wow I had no idea that was her name
not knocking uh I'm not knocking Greer
I'm just
anyway
here we are
uh how are you doing
good I had a crazy experience
um I was on the road this weekend I was
driving to the Denver Airport after my
show to do it to catch a red eye and I
was on that stretch like just before you
get to the stretch with the horse on it
the blue uh Bronco whatever the hell it
is that demonic blue Bronco with the
glowing eyes
it's like a it's like a 20 ton statue
that the sculptor it fell on him he died
while he's making it I didn't know it's
haunted oh wow that's not the crazy part
I was on the expressway and we're
driving and it's I have the runner and I
have Chris Johnson with me and we're in
the car and we're like 10 minutes from
15 minutes from the airport timings and
we hear a pop or no we hear like a a
knock and
I thought we rolled over something on
the expressway and then we heard it
again I'm like maybe it's caught
underneath and then Chris at the same
time thought we were back firing out of
the car and uh and then it happened
again and again and again I go something
just came loose under this car we're
going 80 miles an hour like we had to
pull over like this is gonna be this
could be bad and then the guy was like
what do you think that is he goes oh
that's not you guys banging on the thing
like we go no we look to our left
to our right so we're in the left lane
is the Middle Lane and a right lane
there's no one in between us in the
Middle Lane and the right lane is a car
driving and this guy has his hand out
the window and is firing a gun into the
air on the expressway and it it affected
us such that we felt the car our car
like like something hit our car like I
guess the I don't know how that's
possible from a handgun to go across two
lanes and and we felt like it was
knocking underneath our car we all felt
it we felt every with every pop we felt
our car vibrate it was wild and so this
is Detroit this is Denver and then looks
he goes holy [__] and the guy you see
like the the Flint the Flames but like
this the yeah yeah yeah going out front
of his gun and he just emptied a whole
clip like this if he would have went
like it was like this if he would have
went like this we could have got hit
with a bullet wow and then right as
that's happening a truck big semi truck
the trailer comes speeding in between us
both he wasn't shooting at us I don't
think but like comes in between us and
then we were like holy [__] and so we
were gonna drop back and then we saw him
like speeding and he was shooting like
in front of the truck we just kind of
let him go and call the cops but dude it
was uh like it was definitely a wake up
like a little bit of like a a mind [__]
yeah because you hear about what's like
oh there's someone got hit with a
straight bullet or whatever the hell
this guy fired a full clip into the air
while driving on the expressway broken
tail light Bender hanging off we didn't
know what the [__] but maybe he stole it
that's a wild that's wild yeah man I
mean we felt
we felt we thought every all three of us
thought it was something with our car
that's how much we felt it coming it was
weird I felt it from underneath the car
and Chris did too and that's why I
thought we were back for orange but dude
honestly this this there's not a big
difference between this
and this no I would agree you know I
mean even if he was not even meaning to
you know he was just shooting dude could
you imagine just getting just getting
shot in the car while you're driving
that's [__] up that's really [__] up
hey
so I'm glad to be sitting at a
crime-filled week yeah yeah yeah
I'm in a terrible mood my apartment got
robbed uh uh
thought it was kind of over it but
bunch of stuff dealing with it this
morning in a miserable mood you and I
got into an argument before the show
started would you call it an argument
I'll call it an argument
you don't think there was an argument no
no no
really yeah
all right I don't think we really are
screw it you're saying how we both felt
and then we just settled on something so
we were passionately
I felt like we were arguing no I don't
know maybe debating in my head I wasn't
arguing with you I wasn't arguing with
you I wasn't like mad at you but I felt
that we had it was an escalated
conversation let's put it that way okay
anyway
yeah sure
I get what you mean I I didn't I didn't
think we argued over anything I didn't
think so no no I did you know that pimp
stop with this AI [__] this is half the
reason I'm in a bad mood all right yeah
DeRose the entire industry do you the
entire writers industry is on strike
right now because the they are demanding
that this program not be used to create
first drafts of scripts which is exactly
what I said was going to happen on this
very podcast I said give it time that
will happen and the industry has
wholeheartedly said that is
non-negotiable we will not negotiate
that with you sure so here we are but
what what what and everybody keeps what
did you do he keeps feeding his stuff
into it pulling up weird facts about
each of the food you're debating okay
well remember we used to use Google for
that search engine
and we would uh not ask a computer I
think that's a form of AI
oh God the world's going to [__] uh it's
over with doing cheese Doodles or
popcorn anyway
uh I have cheese noodles you try to keep
us on track here well I'm just I was
about to do something about the cheese
dude
how did cheese doodle get its name okay
because I'm doing cheese dude I thought
maybe you're gonna ask me about how why
I'm having a hard time this week
I thought you were maybe going to ask me
how am I I'm doing my week I thought you
didn't want to talk about it it's been a
hard week
yeah sometimes we say we don't want to
talk but when we need to talk about it
let's talk about it well now it's now
I've had to say it so now I don't want
to talk about it
I'm talking about it
uh I don't know it's just so crazy I
don't know do you ever you never just
felt like the world's over
my house has been robbed but I mean my
hat now look people have been worse than
robbed people have been robbed worse
than me yeah you don't have to say that
there's no caveats needed your house got
right but my point is is you know I'm
talking about getting robbed you're
talking about a guy driving down the
road in Denver shooting a gun out the
window for no apparent reason yeah pimps
feeding an AI engine that the industry
is is is uh about to use as the primary
means to create a writer's room from now
on
it's a beautiful day though
it's a little too hot they're going on
70s it's already a little too much
uh uh you know but I mean yeah I guess
cheese there's still cheese Doodles at
the end of the day I'll tell you it
would be great if you're uh burglar had
just eaten cheese Doodles before he
robbed you yes that would have been good
fingerprints yes and I think that's the
only thing you're gonna have against me
today but anyway I digress that well I
got do you have anybody on the on that
like do you have a lead I can't I don't
think I can talk about any of that
publicly but you know yeah but uh but
then it's a weird experience
you know yeah you never happened to you
before anyone else
broken into home both of you
this is more common than I realize
uh I will say this I will say this this
doesn't give you hope when two or three
of because when it happens they the cops
show up in waves
like first the two cops that get called
by 9-1-1 show up and they're the ones
that start the initial report then
usually two more cops will show up like
hey we got the call do you guys need any
help
then the fingerprint duster person shows
up
then the detectives show up
so you're you're dealing with waves of
law enforcement coming in all
did you get someone's card
I got a lot of cards and phone numbers
yeah yeah but you're dealing with the
movies you know like yeah the guy pulls
out of his code he's like you call me if
you hear anything yeah yeah yeah yeah
you uh you get so you get waves of
people coming in and and and and with
each wave that then they're brought up
to speed on what's going on okay and
then they sort of give their input and
their in their whatever right and you're
like okay
it does not help your spirits when two
or three Law Enforcement Officers
independently of one another say to you
it's getting worse and it's not going to
get any better
like yeah like crime in New York is
it's just you know and you're just going
my God and then I was talking to a
friend of mine yeah who comes to New
York every few months for business
and I was like I don't know man it
doesn't seem that any and he's like dude
you know how much I love New York I was
like yeah and he goes dude I gotta tell
you you're not you don't see it because
you live there he's like I am noticing
the because the decline is evident every
time I come up like it is noticeably wow
dropping off that's not good it's
terrible it's terrible you know we never
found the guy that robbed our place yeah
but we suspected it was a neighbor why
there were some there was some
like uh friction about over something
stupid or something I don't remember
what it was at the time was it over
cheese Doodles no it was not
uh but I don't know man you know what do
you it's it's it's you know it's it kind
of sacks your soul a little bit like I
was just talking to Chris about this
about the perspective
seriously and about about like it does
who someone said the proverb I think it
was gato where it was like um
it was a Chinese swarm what was it and
uh
I'm gonna apply the Chinese form of
proverb to Joe right now all right like
like so I'll I'll bastardize it and make
it my own your house got robbed but what
if a female cop came you fell in love
that became your wife that didn't happen
but my point is is that you never know
what comes out of each and everything
you know what I mean in the proverb
there was a Chinese former and what
happened
got a horse and then yeah so the horse
and then a horse ran away and he was
like oh my God
someone's like what are you gonna do
your horse ran away it's terrible he
goes maybe it's terrible
and the next day the horse returned and
there was two horses following it
you know what I'm saying yeah and then
there was a second example right after
that it was a good one
the sun went on the horse and he broke
his back and then his arm or leg or
something yeah and then the Army came in
to the town and said I'm going to we're
recruiting everyone has to be drafted
right not people that are hurt or
injured yeah so his son avoided to drag
because it's off the horse today before
they thought it was broken arm was bad
but then he didn't have to go to war
yeah no insane is yeah some it'd be nice
if sometimes life could be like a
made-up story that people write you're
saying there was no Chinese form of the
horse I love that people wrote these
things after a terrible thing happened
and said like well what if it was like
this you go well it wasn't but that's
nice yeah I'll go read a few Hallmark
cards while I'm at it trying to think of
the bright side of life
uh no there's the takeaway here's the
takeaway you have a problem floating
around there with the exact opposite
maybe I will meet the love of my life
when I now move out of New York City
because I feel that I might have reached
my limit well think about that because
that that getting robbed then is the
impetus for a completely uh
complete change in your whole entire
trajectory uh and you and and then
anything that comes out of that change
then would be a direct result of you
getting robbed and saying I've had
enough so anything that comes out of
that if you moved now anything that
comes directly related to you not being
here and being there forever is a direct
response to you moving because of that I
absolutely have thought about that I
have thought about like even in just
having to replace things that I own that
were stolen from me and replacing them
choosing to not replace certain things
because you're like you know what man as
mad as I am that that was stolen for me
I don't need it okay so like and then
there were things that I absolutely
needed
that I had to replace that I was like
I think I can replace this for a
fraction of what I spent the first time
around sure because
fear caused me to spend this much extra
on the computer because I didn't want to
run out of whatever and I was like that
was stupid I didn't need to do that so
like little little things like that
absolutely big takeaways
uh I learned how to love sleeping on my
couch that's been a lot of fun
uh why because I'm afraid to sleep in
the bedroom why because you're just
you feel I don't know you're just
freaked you feel too isolated in there
like I'm like I need to know what's
going on in the entire apartment like I
can tell what's happening from the
living room you can see every I've
learned to love that couch
that I've been trying to replace with
your help
um
and also funny enough replacing the
couch suddenly didn't seem that
important anymore you know and you saw
the amount of text I was sending yes I
did about trying to figure out the couch
replacement so maybe it gave you a
little I mean I mean to take not that
it's still wish it didn't happen but you
could take away some Silver Linings from
it there's absolute Silver Linings but I
will say this and I don't want to put
too final point on it and then we can
move on because it's not a the pot I
realize this podcast is in a therapy
session but the fans are quite endearing
and they do show support it's really
lovely therapy uh try betterhelp.com yes
put in the promo code taste buds I have
better we'll be talking to my better
health therapist this week about it uh
the the
I don't want to say negative but the
immediate uh uh conundrum that it poses
is and I'm very serious when I say this
folks very proud that taste buds is
sponsored by betterhelp I am a person
that spends uh or at least I try to
spend a considerable amount of time
working on myself every week it's
something that in the past I didn't do
enough of and I'm glad to be doing it
now and it doesn't matter when you
figure out that you should do it it's
just that if you figure out you need to
do it that you do it better help can
help you do it I am somebody that has
benefited from therapy in the past and
I'm not just saying this better help has
been the easiest and best experience for
me in that area of life it is convenient
it is I am able to reach my therapist uh
and and I'm given many options of times
and uh ways that I can set the sessions
with my therapist you can do phone you
can do chat you can do video calls it's
incredibly convenient it is incredibly
affordable it is incredible easy it's
just an amazing thing if you're thinking
about trying therapy give better help a
try this is the perfect service to allow
you a non-obstical laden way of doing
this so you don't get disheartened by
bureaucratic nonsense that might stand
in your way so find more balance with
better help visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds today you're going to get 10
off your first month that's better help
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash taste buds
folks let's talk about shoes
you know a fancy man like me and a fancy
guy like sour and fancy man like pimp
and a fancy lady like V we like our
shoes around this place and vessey is
making great shoes Game Changer shoes
all right now
uh this is a life hack I'm gonna I'm
gonna share it with you uh you know when
your shoes get wet and Soggy and cold
and then you've gross cold feet all day
uh vessi shoes will literally prevent
that
from ever happening again ever ever ever
I've tried the messy shoes I have two
pair they do exactly what they say
they're gonna do they're comfortable
they're convenient they keep your feet
dry and your feet warm through all the
weather the changes and hits at the
wrong time I know we're coming out of
winter now uh but I gotta tell you New
York is no stranger to rain storms and
it's no stranger to surprise rainstorms
vesi comes in handy with a stylish
waterproof shoe that is very comfortable
that you can walk around in all day a
hundred percent waterproof not water
resistant waterproof
waterproof warm yet somehow lighter and
more comfortable than boots go figure
and they slip on and off so it's quick
and easy to get outside people I've said
all you need to hear here's what I want
you to do all right I want you to visit
vesi.com taste buds for your pair of
vesi shoes vesti.com taste buds you're
going to use the promo code taste buds
and get 15 off your entire order plus
free shipping in Canada the US Australia
Japan some other places that is vesi.com
you're going to use
that is vesi.com taste buds you're going
to use promo code taste buds for 15 off
your entire order again free shipping
Canada U.S Australia New Zealand Japan
folks Joe DeRosa here taking the summer
off from live dates why I'll be around
New York City and where will I be
hanging out well you guessed it I might
be at Joey roses and if you come through
New York I hope you come to Joey roses
too we're open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m every day and we go into the
evening serving food and affordable
drinks all day long go to
joeyrosesnyc.com for all details or
check us out what's up taste buddies I
am on the road with the Impractical
Jokers we are halfway through the tour
adding dates all the time so check out
impracticaljokerslive.com uh coming up
next May 5th and 6th we are in West
Valley City Utah and Denver Colorado May
19 20 and 21 Arlington Texas The Moody
Center in Austin and Sugarland Texas
June 2nd 3rd and 4th Columbus Ohio
Cleveland Ohio and Detroit at the fox
June 15 16 17 Minneapolis Des Moines and
Kansas City and then rounding out the
last posted dates right now in July
we're coming to Nashville to play the
Grand Ole Opry House the game Bridge
Field House in Indianapolis and two at
the stifle theater in St Louis
everything available at
impracticaljokerslive.com
it has
there's a couple other things involved
in this like that that aren't related to
the robbery uh that I don't really want
to speak to but this is probably the
Fifth Element
much like the hit shout out christomer
sequels shout out shout out Bruce Willis
uh much like the fifth L uh this there
the robbery is sort of the fourth or
fifth element or ingredient in a stew of
things that has made me question New
York like and like the concrete jungle
where dreams are made of yeah because my
whole thing with New York was always
man the payoff is always so great you
can make it here you can make it
anywhere and uh the payoff was always so
great you the the return on your
investment it was a hard city to live in
it was expensive it was you had to get
you know a buddy of mine once said
you need to you need to prep before you
go outside you need to get emotionally
ready like New York is not just walk out
your friends yeah down down a driveway
and sure get the mail leisurely with
your cup of coffee it's not that kind of
place
so and the connectivity in all of it is
was a really great thing this again is
the fourth or fifth domino in a chain
but this this I was like
I don't know man like I don't know like
I don't know [__] yeah is that
ice cube yes full circle yep full circle
full circle
um
I don't know I just was like I don't
know if the return is is worth it
anymore like I don't you need to live
here for everything that you do
I've given that a lot of thought and I'm
like I could
I can I can drive in here once a week
you know I can drive in here once I
could drive in here once a week and get
a hotel room for two nights and still
and own a place somewhere else and still
spend probably less money than I spend
renting an apartment in New York
that's that's what I mean that's part of
it it's just like what am I doing I got
something for you
do you really
what do you mean yes I do I have a
vacant place at a really good price
that's good and it's good for the money
we could talk offline
you've if it's the place I'm thinking of
you've quoted me the price and it was
insane no not my place oh okay my place
you well one point when you were
thinking about moving you were like why
don't you rent out this place and I said
how much and you said a number that
turned my pubic hair straight oh no that
was the number to cover my costs that
was even making a profit
um no not that and it's a really good
price and I think it's less than you're
paying now really yeah but what are you
paying now
this isn't good this is a good podcast
nobody's gonna hear it
well that's funny you say that here's
why and bleep this
I want to say a funny thing okay
and bleep it if you have to and you can
tell them if you just believe it this
happening was the first thing that ever
made me go maybe I should move to Staten
Island
I swear to God I started to think I was
like I I'm like I could find a seclusion
out there that I can't I got I will talk
after all right it's priced and ready to
move
that's it's a friend of mine's uh place
a long time friend I wonder if it's the
place I saw all right go ahead all right
anyway and you get a lot of amenities
that you don't get uh and you'll you
know anyway we'll talk about it all
right we'll talk about it I know as a
real estate agent I only take three
percent
all right I appreciate that and I'm glad
to hear we didn't get into an argument I
thought we got into an argument but we
didn't Pimp's saying we didn't he's
shaking his head no I mean if one of us
does something we did
my brain is
we disagreed it's a disaster I mean we
ended up somewhere
this is bad I'm snapping at pimp about
AI I mean you know it's like
this is why the writer's room should be
AI
all right let's battle
because I guess I don't I didn't snap a
UV right all right
pimp I'm sorry I snapped at you I love
you but I don't care I love you no
matter what happens
I know yeah I usually don't think it's
hot in here and it's hot I know we got
to do something about this because it's
only going to get hotter yeah open the
door and if the fans don't like it they
can comment they don't like it
open the door maybe
[__]
um let me think about this uh but the
air should be on in this building or
maybe it's not on yet there's no way
that Arizona feels very cold in the
other room doesn't it
oh you asked
okay
let's do it yep
do you want to do a chant whatever you
want do you want to do a salty or no I
don't know you tell me well because I
got enough aggravation in me right now
that a salty might really kick this into
into high gear in a good way or a bad
way it might just Spike the energy
I'm using your cues right now no don't
just use my cues
be thank you for using my cues yeah but
use your cues too okay all right
I wouldn't mind a salty okay I think
I'll get us laughing okay and I think
we've had enough Heart to Heart okay all
right sure all right ready yeah you
insult me first okay ready yeah it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
it's starting to get salty I don't think
I'm in a position to insult you today
no that no you can't do that well it's
annoying that I can't do that because
you have to control the narrative all
the time
I can't see insulting you today I'm
sorry why because of everything we've
established you it's time to get
something it's starting to get salty
yeah
I don't know
out there I thought you overthought that
okay and I I don't think it's that big a
deal
and uh I
and advice I'm giving to you I should
actually take myself but uh as well and
I will but I really think it's just like
uh I think we
I think sometimes
I'm very guilty of what we overthink
things okay yeah all right that's not
really an insult but a fair criticism
sure all right
ready yeah I watch them like you are a
[__] sucking big [__]
no all right I think that'd be funny if
you go really hard right right
it's time to get done against all the
Exotic and salty I won't go really hard
but I will tell you this I showed up
you and Chris were still going you were
running late on the episode
immediately I texted pimp I said I'm
here he goes they're still going I wrote
Jesus Christ almighty I'm in no [__]
was shaking the phone for a while we're
just trying to find it out and out uh so
uh you know what you
I I yeah
I did overthink and you overthink so I
got mad when you were telling me I was
overthinking because you overthink two
and we both overthink I think we both
overthink and we both do it in different
ways and at different times about
different things and then we don't it's
hard for us to recognize or have empathy
when the other guy is overthinking does
that make sense sure yeah I think that
makes perfect sense yeah yeah that's
what I think
I also think
your your your
all right Cleveland who's turning I just
got lightheaded I just I laughed so hard
I just got lightheaded that's a problem
right because that happens to me a lot
that's not you right you don't laugh and
get light-headed it's when did it start
happening for you
most of my adult life oh okay yeah me
too yeah it'll it's not good
when I laughed at Heartland wheeze I I
get like he had blackout like a brown
out uh all right so what were you living
in
I was gonna say
that uh that
I don't know how to word it I don't know
how to word it and the only wording
coming into my head is too mean and I
don't mean it just mean so I don't want
to say it okay because it's going to be
sound it's gonna come out meaner than I
mean for it to mean but it was funny it
was funny it was funny okay it was about
how you tap out
okay you got a thing that you do where
you'll go like okay whatever
and you it's a strategy that I can't
quite figure out it's something
underhanded about it I assure you if you
mask it as being amicable but I'm like
no there's he's up to something yeah
that's you overthinking
it was like I don't care I'm letting it
go and that's the end of it uh all right
dude I and you know what and just for
the hell of it no matter what happens
I love you
that's the first ever double chant in an
episode ever that's right first time
here time two
b-a-t-t-l-e budge all right here we go
you got Cheetos or sorry cheese noodles
yes I got popcorn and the reason I said
Cheetos is because Cheetos are the only
passable form of a cheese dude it's
funny you say that they are the only not
just holy bread cheese doodle Cheeto is
not a cheese doodle I mean she's doodle
the big puffy curl yes it is they they
are [__] you can't say that's that's uh
that's that's uh proprietary the doodle
it means it's one of those those
circular things now I don't think so I
actually think the cheese doodle is like
Statin Island like the Forgotten burrow
the cheese doodle is like the Dark Horse
the cheese doodle is never in the
conversation but should be it's always
there right below just waiting to pounce
you know presses some teachers are the
big dogs popcorn comes in might be
another big deal top three right there
Then you have all the different things
that fall underneath it that people get
on occasion or this or that and cheese
doodle is not guaranteed cheese doodle
is not guaranteed at a party achito's
not even guaranteed as the cheese snack
because Cheetos exist and they took away
the essence of the doodle and they made
it into something else I since I'm a
child have appreciated cheese Doodles
and that feeling has not left me now
there's a couple things that people will
say that they don't like about cheese
Doodles and I think that if you embrace
the doodle those things are actually
kind of okay
okay I know that the dusty fingers is
the big thing okay and I don't like them
either but you could flick them and then
you wash your hands I don't find the
doodle leaves
strangely
I don't find that the doodle leaves as
bad a Dusty finger as the Cheeto correct
I find the Cheetos Dusty fingerprints to
be quite honestly one of the perks
there's nothing like the finger lick of
the Cheetos okay that's what I was gonna
just saying so cheese Doodles not
leaving that is actually a detriment to
it
and it's strange that it doesn't leave
it because cheese Doodles I was going to
say as you eat them turn to compacted
dust in your mouth I love that they get
so stuck in your teeth they disintegrate
as you're eating them I love it I hate
it I think it's like it's it's like
eating rotten
styrofoam that has cheese flavoring I
like that you can put it in your mouth
and then just feel it melt down to
nothing eat it or just take the bite
immediately and get that crunch I hate
it I actually like that it's puffed and
then it transitions to not being puffed
it's like something's happening in the
mouth you know what I'm saying I hate it
I also like the fact that I don't mind
it when I mean depends you could eat a
cheese doodle in a way that will combat
having to go like this and get it out
you can eat it in a way that won't do
that what way well you know one way you
just put them in and let them melt and
swallow it you don't chew this is that's
bad [__] so no it's true
like holy communion yeah that's exactly
right exactly right and it just like
just like the commodity of Christ
it's like a Cheesy Body of Christ bro
the cheese noodle is a Cheesy Body of
Christ prove me wrong
okay but but I like that you can do that
with you can't do that with a pretzel
you can't do that with a chip you know
all right I don't like that I don't like
I don't trust a food that changes it's
it it's matter it's it's the matter of
it changes
by nothing like it it's just like the
mere fact that it sits touching a
minimal amount of saliva the form of the
food itself changes like I think that's
weird now obviously I realize that
almost any food eventually would do that
but it is so fast you mentioned
styrofoam I mean popcorn is the closest
textural thing to styrofoam that's fair
food that I've ever tasted that's fair
and styrofoam isn't the best wasn't the
right thing the cheese dude the reason I
said styrofoam is because you know
packing peanuts always make you think of
like this but pop
of the just
just three attribute we probably should
have just put butter popcorn in there
because now it's specific cheese doodle
versus every single type of popcorn you
can I'll stick with no but according to
the polls though they're reading it as
popcorn in any form versus she's doing I
didn't I didn't think of that and you're
right they will but but I'll stick to
butter pasta because people are gonna go
I mean caramel cheese I know butter
can't this and then it's like no it was
kind of butter popcorn I'll stick to
butter popcorn let me hit you with I'm
losing this one let me hit you with the
good
you deserve to
you've won so many chiefs I wonder if I
back out and just repul it right now
it's butter with this you know what this
season is with your losses it's Penance
for the first season we're all the
people that that voted for you early on
because they knew what food you were
picking and they just went with you
because they liked you what about the
second and now they've seen who you
really are and the justice is being
served
look how long it took for us to become
really good friends about three years
takes about three years for me to really
grow on somebody okay and then once I'm
in they can't get enough all right so it
took about 100 120 hours think about how
much I annoy you I annoy you I would I
would beg to you mean when you say you
you mean you the Royal you
I would say I probably annoy you more
than any other friend you have why would
you say that because I've seen it happen
and I've just I I would just be willing
to bet I have a quality that I'm good at
it I just want to annoy people I would
say I annoy you know like more than most
people you know yet I didn't say yet I'm
still top list for invite whatever's
happening
reflecting on all this
yeah you're right why do I keep having
you around
I still will get grief and guilt if I
can't make it if I gotta cancel you'll
be like come on there are times I'm
sitting there going what is this guy
ever I don't understand about being a
friend no I'm saying I would understand
if I was giving him crap
this is all directed at me the uh here's
my point uh popcorn let's hit you with
the popcorn attributes okay number one
so low in calories amazing it is a snack
you can eat now you are talking about
air popped untouched popcorn not
anything with butter even if you pop
even if you pop an oil it's still very
low calorie uh it's it's not it's not
high calorie air pop is easy to come by
uh you know you put some salt on it you
can put real butter on it if you want uh
I mean look nothing obviously tastes
better than the movie butter serum
whatever the hell that stuff is it's
nowhere near butter it tastes amazing I
know that that's bad for you but popcorn
as a whole popcorn is the snack I
started eating
when uh I started eating it about a year
or two ago because Ari shaffir said to
me
I eat popcorn every night and I said why
and he said because it's something you
can eat as a snack it's crunchy there's
a lot of it you can keep going back to
it it fills you up enough and he goes
it's just perfect for sitting on the
couch and I was like holy [__] you're
right you can eat like two cups of
popcorn it's like 175 calories if you
don't put butter on it I don't put
butter on mine I go salted that's it I
do straight up salted microwave popcorn
I got the thing I got the the canister
and I put the seeds in and are the
kernels in and I pop it now cheese
doodles
five
two not great though you'll be surprised
you get a good amount too for the
serving size I bet me with some calories
I bet you for serving you could eat like
15 to 20 puffs
and they're big 15 well at least I think
they're gonna tell you in grams but let
me explain something to you about all
the things I hate about popcorn
number one you talked about styrofoam I
don't like the consistency of popcorn
okay that's number one
I sometimes you sometimes you know when
you're eating popcorn and you actually
like hear that like squeak because
you're biting it and it almost is like
you're biting styrofoam yeah that squeak
I hate that number two you talk about
going like this in your teeth popcorn is
the number one offender of that I mean I
I've never eaten popcorn where an hour
later I wasn't like God damn it and I'm
trying to get this [__] flaky from
the seed you get the you get a layer of
Kernel in between your teeth sometimes a
floss will knock out in two seconds
your teeth are not compacted with junk
after you eat cheese noodles the end
dude while you're still enjoying them
you're cleaning your teeth well I'll put
it to you this way since I'm it's going
to be used against me that you have
every flavor of popcorn in this battle
then I'll just apply it there if you
have cheese dusted popcorn you're
dealing with the exact same thing as the
cheese doodle you're gonna have it on
your fingers no you have a [__] all over
your teeth no no no cheese popcorn does
not compact in your teeth the way cheese
does because of the vehicle itself the
vehicle for cheese popcorn is still
popcorn the vehicle for cheese doodle is
the doodle and the doodle is the problem
not to mention you gotta God knows what
cheese on that thing I'm talking about
movie butter not being real you're not
there's not a speck of real cheese in
that cheese well then I mean anything
you ever add to the popcorn that you'd
there's no adding I'm already pure
version but if it but if all versions
are in the argument which they're going
to be because we just put popcorn then I
could I should be able to use those
other version but they're not because
I'm not art it doesn't matter they're
going to vote the way they vote but I'm
not arguing I'm not arguing the people
are voting industry that's fine but but
my point is this no and you're wrong
candy corn there's there it's it's
caramel it's it's there there's
something there's some there's some
semblance of a real ingredient there as
part of dude cheese dust on a cheese
doodle is the most
manufactured food stuff on planet Earth
it's like there it is like that is like
a go-to any dietitian would be like well
never ingest this ever but any any
single popcorn that's not air pop with
nothing on it is the same exact
difference I disagree how so caramel
cheese no I no no I'm I'll give you the
cheese one Kettle sweet I'm saying no
dude that's like it's like that's like
the caramel I Pro look it up I promise
you caramel popcorn has fewer and more
real ingredients than cheese Doodles do
I think that they just probably have
some some cheese powder on there and
you're going oh it's going way too far
the other way I want to know what what
makes up cheese powder folks you got
subscriptions that you forget about I
know I do oh boy I hope this podcast
isn't one of them how dare you it's free
okay listen rocket money is going to
help you keep track of those
subscriptions you're paying for and it's
going to put it all in one place for you
it's going to keep you up to date so you
know what you're spending every month on
subscriptions okay uh I have found it
very tricky over the past few years with
our lives becoming more and more
subscription based and how to keep track
of all of it the other issue is you're
subscribing to things in different uh
through different platforms maybe you
subscribe through the App Store on on
your Apple or your or your uh Android
device maybe you do it in Google
whatever it is the point is is it's hard
to keep track of all of it and Rocket
money is going to help you do that also
you're gonna get to try it free for 30
days okay how about that rocket money
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions you
got to tell it to cancel it won't just
cancel it but you know you know how that
goes it monitors your spending it helps
you lower your bills it's all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions that they forget about and
chances are you're one of those 80 why
because that's the majority of people
rocket money quickly and easily finding
those subscriptions for you and for any
you don't want to pay for anymore you
just hit cancel and it's done it's that
easy anyway stop throwing your money
away cancel The Unwanted subscriptions
manage your expenses the easy way go to
rocketmoney.com tastebuds
rocketmoney.com tastebuds that's
rocketmoney.com taste buds
nuts.com
loveandnuts.com what is nuts.com well
they're your One-Stop shop for freshly
roasted nuts dried fruit sweets Pantry
Staples like specialty flowers and more
what a wide selection it means there's
something out there for everyone at
nuts.com
uh I like what they're doing they got
plenty of gluten-free options they've
got organic choices they've got other
diet friendly products
whether you're looking for something
sweet and savory or you just need to
stock up on every day cooking Essentials
as I said you're bound to find something
to try you can shop a la carte at any
time or opt into the hassle-free auto
deliveries so you never run out of your
favorite items I have a bunch of stuff
from nuts.com I have a really delicious
trail mix I have some dried mango I have
some almonds uh I have some uh
chocolatey uh chocolatey something dark
chocolatey something or others they're
very delicious
I like this because I'm somebody that
does like to snack at the end of the day
and it's hard to find a snack that isn't
bad for you uh and for me nuts.com is a
really easy way to locate that snack and
by the way find it without any of the
bad stuff in it uh you know like I you
know sometimes you go to the story try
to buy trail mix but everything's got
sugar you don't want the sugar blah blah
blah I'm telling you if you're like me
nuts.com is for you so they're offering
new customers a free gift with purchase
and free shipping on orders of 29 or
more at nuts.com taste buds so check out
all the delicious options at nuts.com
taste buds you'll receive a free gift
and free shipping when you spend 29 or
more that's nuts.com taste buds it's
nothing it's the [__] in the packet
inside the mac and cheese box that
doesn't need to be refrigerated it's she
just hit it she just hit on that it's
cheese it doesn't need to be
refrigerated dude that's your first tip
right there it's cheese that doesn't
need to be refrigerated but no not sure
it's crazy same thing with cheese
popcorn stop I'm not arguing cheese
popcorn but it is this because you're
arguing for popcorn I'm not no no you're
doing a cheap thing right now no I'm not
you you're gonna give me your defense
but it's not the way people are gonna be
waiting no we're not listen I said I
will give you cheese popcorn
but I'm not arguing cheese popcorn I'm
saying popcorn I I'm not arguing popcorn
I'm arguing the the worst part of your
food okay so it's a horrible thing I
have options to make mine better I have
other flavors to make mine better or
healthier you have no option your cheese
doodle is always the worst thing well
you can do a DIY at home but cheese
Doodles themselves a soul with tons of
options you just pulled up 10 flavors
but I'm saying the basis is always the
cheese dust which is one of the worst
things you could ever put in your body
if we're talking about nutrition fine
but if we're just talking about the
eating experience of it the texture and
The Taste I'm taking cheese Doodles all
the time apartment I don't like pop by
the way as a matter of fact popcorn is
one of the very few foods that if I eat
it I will be tasting and burping up
popcorn definitely for the rest of the
day if not the next day popcorn I you
taste popcorn like eight hours later
you're like oh yeah I forgot I had
popcorn what it's the lightest
you don't ever ever
hours later be like oh I just oh it
tastes literally never it is the
lightest fluffiest you eat it you're
like I almost didn't eat anything like
it's there's nothing when you buy a
bedroom and here's the thing I hate
though what about this
hold on a second when you buy a bag of
what there's hardly any what like you
probably like a small bag of like uh
popcorn I it's like a fistful I've never
bought popcorn and it's like snack bags
like this I couldn't speak to it yeah so
here's the other thing making them at
home right you can't make mine at home
you make yours at home yeah I mean come
on what how many of them don't pop
if you're using a machine if you're
doing on the stove they just don't pop
uh I I get it I have a high pop ratio
because I've there's a learning curve
but I've learned how to do it I will
give you
hot
just made popcorn
I that's I mean I I like hot bring
something to the table for me but even
so there's been bowls of popcorn in
front of me I'm on the couch whatever
and I people like eating the popo eating
the popcorn it's the big bowl it's the
only thing out I won't eat popcorn
I understand but I'm just not it's just
it takes over your whole mouth it's just
so like oh this is a week I feel popcorn
I taste and burp and feel popcorn for
hours after that's that's I don't buy I
don't believe that I don't believe that
I'm lying to you I don't I just I I
don't I just could never I could if you
put a gun to my head right now and you
said think of a food that sticks with
you less and repeats less than popcorn I
would be hard-pressed for me popcorn on
top of that list I would be hard-pressed
by the way did you say a minute ago you
could make cheese Doodles at home I said
you can't you can make popcorn okay so
if you can let's talk about that and how
many times that they just leave and then
what about when you when you go into the
bowl right and you scoop them in your
mouth and you don't realize you've got
an unpopped kernel in and you bite down
on that that's a real son of a [__]
that's I can't I can't tell you that I
remember that ever happening to me but
I'm sure it has if they sold buckets of
cheese Doodles at the movies right I
think people would buy the buckets the
country nobody would have a job no the
more popcorn they dump they dump a cup
full of hydrogenated oils still it's
still it's no that's butter butter
cheese I way to a heart attack did you
see the ingredients by the way here's
what I mean caramel popcorn ingredients
popcorn brown sugar corn syrup butter
vanilla extract baking soda boom out the
door give me cheese doodle ingredients
what was that like a make it a home
recipe though yeah look at the side of a
bag all right well let's let's look at
the side of bags yeah like look at that
all right cheese Doodles cornmeal away
salt cornstarch corn flour a lot of
corns cornmeal calcium carbonate
buttermilk cheddar cheese
huh all right well it looks like it cuts
off there's an ellipses there
but uh
I mean without a doubt there's there's
artificial coloring in there I gotta say
it's it's I gotta say it's way better
ingredients 23 pieces
see and I said I said 15 to 19. okay 23
pieces is 150 calories how much popcorn
is 150 calories
probably uh
a cup and a half maybe
yeah we're not gonna I'm not gonna
understand this
conversion metrics no no you can change
the quantity there's a drop down oh 28
grams it's the same one ounce
it's one ounce one ounce is one ounce
okay so I don't know how much popcorn
that is but one ounce soap pimp how many
cup how many cups are in an ounce of
popcorn
four to five cups of popcorn contains
150 calories that's wild dude so another
thing about the popcorn right because
it's let's let's talk about something he
said as a bonus that I think can be made
into a negative you said it's light you
can keep eating it it's the food that
crunches a you just keep eating it keep
eating it it eventually fills you out
keep eating apart is what I've seen is a
is a big problem with popcorn because
people the way they sell that in the
movie theater and the way people pop a
whole bag into a bowl a salad bowl this
big and put some you just keep eating it
until it's done I I I've never seen
people stop eating popcorn I stop all
the time in the movies
I've I don't see it I I get myself and I
do popcorn it inherently has that issue
that people eat it until you get if you
nearly get sick of it you're like what
am I doing I can't believe I'm deleting
this oh God I finished the whole [__]
bag I get my fill I mean dude I mean by
the way speaking of the movies we're
talking about I mean this is it dude
this is the entertainment snack period
popcorn dude they don't sell cheese
Doodles you said earlier what if they
put them in a big bucket they don't even
sell them in a little bucket they don't
sell them in a little packet they're not
they're nowhere to be found at a movie
theater nowhere to be found you're going
up against the I mean this is America
it's the ultimate movie snack but it's
not because it's good it's because it
could it they can make it they can it's
like they're making it fresh for you and
hot there and it smells and it's hot and
so it sells well it's in that kind of
environment it's the number one Carnival
snack it's like by vendors in the park
popcorn I don't think there's another
one Carnival snack you dude you you
popcorn is it's Americana it's warm it's
fluffy it's it's God you see somebody
walking around with the bag you're like
I just think it's so overrated
it really is overrated I'm telling you
the the low calorie count is is one of
the reasons they sell that in the movies
is because you can sit there and eat it
for two hours and go I ingested 150
calories I do not think that they are
thinking about calorie intake when they
decided to put popcorn in the movies I
think that's I think at one point that
that by the way it's the most ancient
treat on Earth
uh archaeologists have found popcorn
fossils this thing has been I mean we've
been running it forever and also people
back in the day had bad teeth and they
still managed to get it down
what will popcorn cart in the 1880s all
right yeah I mean look we said popcorn
we didn't say butter but honestly I
would probably still lose to butter
popcorn
but
I mean everything in the comments is
good everything is going to be like let
me say one puffy cheese that's the same
flavor or this this all right but you're
but you've made that point like why do
you keep going back to it because
because that's where that's going to be
my that's Billy mumford's downfall but I
mean it's it's you know I I would focus
on making a stronger argument for your
food strawberry cheese Doodles in Japan
of strawberry Doodles the strawberry
cheese Doodles uh you know that actually
that is what the the cheese dude reminds
me of is the is is like the what are
those wafers called
that come in vanilla chocolate
strawberry and the Wafers are they just
called Wafers I think they're probably
like cookie Wafers not Nella Wafers
because those are cookies no I know what
you mean yeah no no we're
um yeah they're Wafers yeah yeah
I like those too oh you want to you want
to take that to another level I like to
check out quadratinis what's
quadratini's sugar Wafers that's what
sugar pull up quadratinis good luck
smelling it buddy
yeah there they are good job baby
I've had these they're the Italian yeah
they're very good they're very very good
they're very very good
uh for some reason I like it in that
form I don't like it in the doodle form
the doodle form it bothers me and that
maybe because you eat less of these
they're gonna say it's for kids and look
did I have more cheese Doodles as a kid
per capita than I do today of course I
think I've had more snacks all around
than I do today but I'm not gonna
relegate cheese Doodles for as a kid
food I'm not gonna have them say uh any
adults that's eating cheese Doodles is
that blah blah blah blah blah yeah ah a
Cheetos if I was five this is the this
is what we're gonna hear on the phones
here you know let's start and I'm saying
I'm saying that I'm saying let's let's
why can't we have Jesus why did cheese
do this exclusively for kids because
they suck and a child thinks they taste
good I didn't even like them as a kid I
had Cheetos first and when I was
introduced to cheese noodles I was like
these are like bad Cheetos like these
this is the Doodles came before the
cheetah I know I'm saying I had Cheetos
first and then I had cheese Doodles and
I was like this is a shittier version of
the look the Cheeto took the idea that
she's so they go let's fix everything
wrong with this thing we're going to
give you more cheese dust we're gonna
give you a crunch they're not gonna
disintegrate as they sit on your tongue
we're gonna all they do they
disintegrate
dude all they did was change the shape
that's all they did no that's not true
so Cheetos have a crunch that cheese
dude because they change the shape to
that like they're harder too though it's
the the consistency well yeah that's
that's what that's what I mean when I
say they changed uh yeah well that's a
huge change but what you're the final
result that you're swallowing is very
similar
and you like Cheetos I can tell you
right now if I'm not it's not that big
if you offered me a bag of Cheetos I'd
leap at them if you offered me a bag of
cheese Doodles I'd say no thank you a
marketing the way you're saying with uh
popcorn I've been to parties where
there's bowls of cheese Doodles out I
think it's I I don't even go near them I
think they are a waste of a snack
they're a waste of calories okay they're
an absolute waste of calories they don't
taste great the consistency sucks uh and
cheetah I'm like this is this is a bad I
feel that the same way about like like
when you have a good sour cream and
onion chip it's you know what here's a
better example there's Doritos and
there's everything else
there's the there's a million other
nacho cheese chips out there corn chips
they suck Doritos are King Chip so what
is it comparing that to Cheetos are the
king version of this and then everything
else is so secondary yeah I think it's
not the exact same thing but let me just
say one more thing about the popcorn
which I which is like the the nail in
the coffin for me we talked about it
getting in the teeth
what about one of those stupid little
brown outer freaking seed flakes
kernels get stuck to the top back roof
of your mouth
I think you're going to bring up this
hacky argument hacky it's the worst
feeling you have to go and then you have
to put your finger in the back of your
throat and like just swipe around where
the [__] thing interesting
observation I've never heard this before
why don't you do read it as a closer Are
you seriously you never heard it I'm no
I'm dead I'm not serious I'm being
sarcastic oh okay well I'm not I'm not
talking about it like it's a closing bit
I mean I'm just saying it's such a yeah
we know we're all aware we know what
we're talking about that's like that's
like arguing ice cream headache it's
like we're aware of it he's got cheese
on your fingers I didn't argue cheese on
your fingers did you hear me argue it
you didn't well you brought it up no I
didn't I said I think it's a bonus I did
quite the opposite because I'm gonna I
mean I'm interested are you saying not
to bring up a point no I'm saying it's
it's such an awesome feeling you can't
get it you just can't get it yeah it's
it's it's it couldn't be less of a
deterrent oh for me that makes me hate
popcorn I want to fight it couldn't be
less of a detour it's like saying I
won't drink a slurp because of the cause
I'll get the brain freeze I don't care
yeah I know I can't control if the
Colonel's getting stuck to the roof of
your mouth you can control brain freeze
you get a delicious Slurpee in front of
you it's a hot summer day branches have
a little bit of really yeah really you
can't even get popcorn down and chewed
up enough that you're not choking on it
you're something you choke on popcorn uh
I don't check on choke on cheese Doodles
all right let's go to the phones
I go for popcorn although it's a death
trap
hot and that's it that's true you have a
stale popcorn
yeah
we're still talking about it real quick
no it does yes it does leave popcorn out
for a day have it the next day you're
eating styrofoam container cubes that's
right the [__] is a cheese dude I saw a
few people say that that's very funny I
don't get that
cheese doodle sounds like a term for
getting touched inappropriately at the
fair
eat cheese Doodles at the front of every
movie he's either just saying thank you
Joe has to be teams Doodles because it's
PA based no I had to Google cheese
doodle because what the f is that how do
you not know what a cheese doodle is bro
tries to argue that the messy fingers is
a positive thing I'm gonna off myself I
argued against him and I said it was
positive
cheese Doodles because I'd rather have
cheesy covered fingers uh than those
[__] pieces of stale popcorn in my
teeth and there's no lingering burnt
popcorn smelling up in the house for
days like yourself
I hate that too popcorn smell for days
stop it no you know that's ridiculous
you live in a building you know when
your neighbor's making popcorn stop it I
come into your apartment I know that you
made popcorn I don't like smelling
popcorn for the rest of the day and I
don't like my clothes smelling like
popcorn none of that happens with the
doodle
uh I can't believe you like food very
down south I had to Google nobody knows
what to use those huh
uh well I said you could take Cheeto you
said no popcorn is just so much more
versatile by the way that's the first
time somebody has made this argument you
said everybody was gonna say nobody
nobody I should have said every because
everyone doesn't know what a
cheeseburger caught up on that there's
ten things already I mean excuses
excuses
I should have said peach cobbler that
was episode three you didn't you said
you didn't want to go brand against
popcorn you know uh I said popcorn you
don't specify on puffy on crunchy cheese
noodles
uh
uh if is cheese doodle an old person
thing white cheddar defeats all
do they sell cheese Doodles at a movie
theater no thank you very much all right
let's uh let's give the win getting the
inner piece of popcorn stuck on your
tooth and unable to remove it it
probably has to how it feels debating
Joey D she's Doodle for the wind Buddies
thank you Molly Asher you want to give
Molly Asher the win let's give Molly
Asher the win we gotta wrap this up
because we got our quest for the next
episode all right
and uh I mean I mean it's just a matter
of is it in the 90 tens am I am I in
single digits I don't know yet well they
don't know what cheese Doodles are all
right relax we got 5 000 votes ready
all right all right so we knew popcorn
was ring but actually not as bad as I
thought
77 popcorn to 23 cheese doodle and I do
believe if we said butter popcorn it
would be a little less
do you smell that
burnt it's not burnt popcorn
it's a comeback [__]
you're talking trash in year three
still love you I love you too
fools
gonna taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic I'm talking